let's go next to our caller from the 541
area code who's calling today from 541
hi David this is Jordan from Eugene
Orton hey Jordan what's up hi I tweeted
you about this Jay today but I thought
I'd call you for the first time and I
had a thought um when it comes to the
impeachment and right now Nancy Pelosi
is holding the articles for going to the
Senate yes budget ever going to trial so
it's kind of weird stalemate is it
possible that we can go into the next
presidential election
assuming that Trump loses office and
someone else gets in that they can
actually have a trial after there is a
new president on Trump you know I don't
know the answer to that to be perfectly
frank so so the idea would be Nancy
Pelosi holds articles of impeachment the
president has been impeached then Trump
loses and then you have a different
president in but you still do an
impeachment trial Trump I think that you
prop my instinct is you can't because
impeachment is an impeachment trial is
ultimately a vote about whether to
remove the president if the president's
already gone it makes it moot and maybe
it could still have some symbolic
meaning but I don't think so I think
you've got to do I think you've got to
do the impeachment trial while the
president is still president I mean that
makes a lot of sense the only thing I
was thinking about was because
technically since no one has ever been
convicted just in my mind from a trial
that so there's never really been a
consequence other than removing a
president because there potentially
could be additional consequences rather
than just other than just being removed
that's why I was thinking that way well
there can be once the president is no
longer president they can conceivably
could be indicted for crimes but it's
it's I I think our priority should be
let's remove him in November no matter
what and at a certain point let's let's
do the trial in the Senate probably
before the election I think it has to be
but maybe Nancy Pelosi knows better than
I do a good possibility
I enjoyed hearing your thoughts David
thank you very much all right thank you
appreciate the call thanks very much